a while ago I sat down with legendary
Warner Brothers animator Bruce Timm and
we cooked up a Conan superhero called
the flaming sea anyway since he and I we
created it and hit this is the flaming
sea in about ten minutes and since then
the flaming sea has taken on a life of
its own it all came to a head this past
weekend at comic-con in San Diego okay
yeah I went to I went to comic-con for
the first time I'd never been it was
amazing I visited an art gallery filled
with flaming sea artwork made by our
fans we have very talented artistic fans
they made this flaming sea artwork they
had an art gallery I visited and I also
dropped in on a comic-con flaming sea
panel discussion we brought a camera
crew because we still can't believe it
all happened and well here it enfold
take a look
[Music]
check this out this is a photo of the
first comic-con she's back in FC 1894
and the superhero then was a guy who
didn't have cholera that's my entire
speech that's all like well I'm just
here to visit the the exhibit I heard so
much about it this is fantastic this was
all made illegally I never gave my
permission
but it's beautiful look at that that is
impressive
he's got a rolodex from an office Jam
who did this one why would you have one
where I'm getting the kicked out
what is this are they actually have a
they have oven mitts I'm not making any
money off any of this crap I'm so angry
and this is a cape they're giving out
yeah wow that's highly flammable
why are there all these guys tonight if
these gentlemen that are working
security can you step forward please
just for a second I'm trying to create
this fun happy sexy atmosphere and
they've hired guys from the Central
Intelligence Agency to be here I just
want to ask you how can it be as manly
and sexually appealing as you are to
women you're terrific do would you like
a job what is your name Jose okay Jose
what I do
don't touch bad security why did you let
him touch me we've got 45 guys here in
black suits women can touch men no
touchy it really is like being an ape at
the San Diego Zoo hi how are you I mean
I could talk to them but I have no
immune system oh is this you did you
make that this is a flaming sea made of
how many Legos sir 30,000 LEGO bricks
thirty thousand two and a half weeks of
my life building this beast now let's be
fair if you hadn't been building this
you'd have spent two and a half weeks
making a giant Chewbacca this is
heartwarming to just come and see the
amount of work that he's put into this
and it's just an absolute thrill so give
yourselves a hand you guys are the back
[Applause]
and now give me a bigger hand
[Music]
Colonel Brian
any questions oh hey you've got their
oven mitt and everything awesome you're
great
what's that okay saddest thing anyone's
ever shouted out in the history of
comic-con I have the oven mitt to
we go this this is the moment I've been
waiting for all my life who are you
what's your character
I'm ganthet from Green Lantern yes I
knew that
yeah how you do use someone who has a
ring you don't have a ring no I give the
ring he bestows the ring yeah he you
know and they regulate the Green Lantern
culture yeah you got to regulate those
things yeah
anything else I'm good yeah
you are one laid-back
giver of the Rings here's your ring
whatever for tech stuff oh are you
justice yeah claiming see yeah yeah
oh my god
[Applause]
nice to meet you listen what is your
name sir okay Casey sit up
why would you out Casey I think Casey's
got a hookup Casey right now again
please she's right back there go to her
Casey she loves you oh my god security
[Applause]
you